well today i have a a guest who's a
little different in terms of his
background he's not one of these
established internet polyglots he's a
person that i met on twitter who is
interested in vocabulary acquisition who
has a podcast and i just thought that
would be an interesting person to talk
to on my channel so welcome keith
good morning i don't know if it's
morning where you are but it's morning
here it's still morning still morning
can you please introduce yourself
yeah sure uh first of all thanks for
having me you know when i responded to
your tweet on twitter i was pretty blown
away i've actually uh
looked up to you for a little bit for
these past couple of years when i was
learning spanish because i listened and
watched some of your videos some of your
older ones when you were talking about
language acquisition so
it's great to be here but as far as my
uh background so i am a math teacher
currently
i've been learning languages the first
language that i started learning in high
school was french did about two years in
french and got to college actually
tested into japanese got thrown in
pushed in um wasn't very good at it at
least i didn't feel like it went on an
immersion in college and i just kind of
fell in love with the language because i
really felt loves like whoa i can
actually learn a foreign language that's
pretty cool
um and since then i've just kind of
dabbled in a few languages but i did
decide to become a spanish court
interpreter about four years ago
so i obviously needed to learn a large
amount of spanish for that and
i
became pretty much professionally fluent
in spanish to where i can use it now on
the job i did some freelance
interpreting at the time obviously i'm a
teacher now so it didn't work out for
like the long run but i'm fluent in
spanish and since then i've gone on i'm
actually currently
probably low intermediate level in
mandarin chinese so wow yeah so so okay
so spanish so spanish is you know fluent
yeah uh mandarin chinese is low
intermediate are there any and japanese
was kind of put on pause
yeah french is still there in the
background or
no no i know the french i have to say i
i don't remember very much from high
school
so and and of course where we connected
on twitter was around the discussion of
vocabulary acquisition yeah and did i
understand that you have written a book
i have yeah the book's called the tower
of babbling and basically what it is is
kind of a
a summation of all of my experiences
learning languages and what i wanted to
do was i wanted because i when i was
learning for my interpreting class i
never found resources for someone who
went from like
dabbling to like fluent professionally
fluent so that's basically what i wanted
to do with my book i wanted to take out
like all the anecdotes no fluff just
completely actionable steps what do i
need to do what do i need to not do in
order to organize my language learning
better
now uh you have a podcast perhaps you
should tell us the name of your podcast
the day with the budget yeah sure yeah
the name of the podcast is the same as
the book it's the tower of babbling
podcast right um and essentially what i
i didn't really have a plan like if you
listen to the first episode i literally
say i just have the book with me and i
press record you know so
um basically i'm just reading the book
and then i'm providing kind of like
um author
anecdotes kind of author's notes if you
will as i read and then sometimes after
i read i i focus on key points that i
would want to know if i were
studying whatever language
at that point
the uh of course the the podcast then
doesn't it's not word for word
uh the book no it's it's on its own and
there are no transcripts to the podcast
no no transcripts at this time no okay
no i only asked that because i find very
often podcasts are such tremendous
language learning absolute resources
yeah and i use them for you know persian
whatever arabic and so often in fact in
most cases there are no transcripts if
we had a transcript if we had
transcripts to your podcast we could put
them into link as
lessons you know when people can learn
from them so absolutely about language
learning and they'd learn english
and that was learning english and that
is definitely something that i would
like to look into actually i was
experimenting with uh using google docs
they have a voice translation feature
where you can basically
shadow the podcast and then it just
records it right then and there so i did
that a little bit and that's you'd have
to go back into correct it right
absolutely oh yeah
okay so uh now on the subject of uh
vocabulary acquisition yeah do you refer
specifically to your spanish experience
or you talk about other languages as
well no i talk about other languages and
in my book it's prevalent really spanish
and japanese because i actually i didn't
mention it earlier but i have a minor in
japanese which okay
yeah it's probably best as a minor i'm
glad i didn't major in it because my
japanese isn't that good um
but yeah i do talk about other languages
and my book is meant to be a general
resource meaning that you can slap any
language whatever you know congolese
whatever and that if it's meant to be a
structural thing so yeah i definitely
pull from my experiences learning all
languages
can you share with uh our viewers uh you
know some of the key points like what
are some of the principles or things
that we need to be aware of and because
everybody
i mean i believe
when i started link i said the most
important single measure of our
potential in a language is how many
words we know absolutely yeah that that
because you can you can be very good at
saying a few things you know hello how
are you my name is sure you don't have a
lot of words you're not going to
understand very much you can't read you
can't say much so
and the more words you have and
typically we acquire words through
typically a lot of reading and listening
so it's kind of a measure of the fact
that you have been engaged with this
language to me it's such a tremendously
important
number how many words do you know
yeah passively i'm talking about not
necessarily because you're going to use
a small subset of those so question so
therefore what are some of your
principles sort of observations
recommendations when it comes to
acquiring words
uh good question and my absolutely like
number one thing anybody asked me about
learning languages and learning a large
amount of vocabulary is having a system
for vocabulary and of course you have
link and i've actually used link and i
it is i like the way it keeps track of
the words because that it like you said
it is a fantastic measure but that was
one of the big issues that i had early
on was i didn't have a way to capture
all of these words and i've got the
spirals behind me to prove it basically
i have like
six spirals full of spanish vocabulary
some of its legal vocabulary some some
of its medical some of it's just
vocabulary i picked up watching netflix
but i didn't have a way to get it in you
know like i would write it down and
because i'm a big writer and i agree
like with that kinesthetic um kind of
inclusion that element of getting
vocabulary in but i didn't have a system
to go back and review these things so
i would hear the word and be like i
don't know that word write it down but
said it and forget it you know and i
forgot it most of the times so
really it was once i got that system in
place and kind of found a way to like
okay i'm i'm going to get it down and
then i'm going to review it again that's
when
the magic started happening and my
vocabulary kind of exploded from there
and and can you share with us uh some
elements of what that system is
yeah sure so
really what i try and do is i try and
include
several aspects of
the like i mentioned the kinesthetic so
i i i'm trying to remember how many um
actual elements that i have but
the elements
to learning the vocabulary so i talk
about the kinesthetic i talk about
having an emotional connection that's
one of the things i mentioned in my book
is why do we remember curse words and
um offensive lines those are the first
things that people kind of pick up in
languages because they're kind of
emotional anytime you see them in
context they're kind of just like
blurted out and they're like whoa this
is really kind of a shock to your brain
so having that emotional connection
really helps solidify it and then i also
try and incorporate
the visual element so one of the things
i'll do is i'll
find a word that i don't know and then
i'll go and just google images and look
it up in spanish or i'll look it up in
whatever language and i'll be like oh so
that's what it actually looks like and
because it's on google probably a native
speaker posted it
in that language so i get more of a
sense i can kind of have another hook to
hook the language on so i should
actually do all of this through anki i i
feel like anki was a very powerful tool
because i could make flash cards that
would have
the
the english the language i was trying to
learn which was spanish at the time and
then i could have a picture in there
that i could place from online so when i
bring all of these things together it
really makes for some powerful
vocabulary acquisition like you're not
going to easily forget some of these
words right
i think it's very important that uh
you know i i say like if you're going to
succeed in language learning you have to
be confident that you can do it yes you
have to be confident that it's
worthwhile doing yeah and you have to be
confident that the method you're using
works yes and i think
that's where like language learning is
an individual journey like i always say
don't criticize other people don't
actually say that you know you're you're
japanese is lousy or you made a mistake
and you're french of course everybody
does their own thing
everybody
derives pleasure out of learning the
language out of what they have achieved
yeah and finding their own way so
uh
personally i would not
maybe i'm too lazy to do all the things
that you're suggesting that people do
but i know a lot of people
like doing those kinds of things and
derive tremendous benefit from them
and i think to to point out what these
different approaches are and how they
can be used
is tremendously useful
so and is so that's in your book and
your book is listed on your website on
your uh podcast website it's on my
website yes it's keith hayden.net and
and in your podcast you talk about some
of these methods or what what is that
what is the kind of what do you talk
about
or what are you going to be talking
about in your in your podcast yeah so in
the podcast episodes i basically what i
do is the structure is always kind of
the same i introduce the topic that i'm
going to talk about and then i kind of
say you know kind of where we're going
and then i'll read that section of the
book and then sometimes throughout the
reading and then other times afterwards
i kind of break down
uh what i would i kind of pull out the
meat if you will you know i kind of pull
out exactly okay here's what you could
go do right now here's what i had
trouble with when i was really thinking
about this aspect of language learning
and i feel like that's what other people
probably struggle with too maybe on
their own but right
yeah and then i also started including
some uh twitter polls and things like
that i'll ask questions like how do you
do this how do you i did one on grammar
a couple days ago and i did a twitter
poll how do people study grammar and
then i talk about those and then i try
and give some homework too you know in
typical teacher fashion yeah yeah yeah
you know what's interesting is you said
we were just talking before we started
that uh
part of your motivation for starting the
podcast is because everybody's locked
down and uh yeah you know we got to a
find things useful to do yeah b you want
to connect with other people who are in
a similar situation yeah and i think
that's really valuable
uh
we at link we started our live streams
with that in mind like people have like
the world hasn't come to an end and no
absolutely we have different ways of of
connecting
and uh people are are interest many
people are interested in learning
languages and yeah
looking for their own approaches and
stuff and i think this is tremendously
valuable and uh podcast has the
advantage that people can just pick up
the podcast and go off and do whatever
they're doing and they can be listening
to your podcast and getting a lot of
valuable
input absolutely uh yeah and and as i
say eventually if you have transcripts
we could put those as lessons into link
and people know the speakers of english
could then be you know getting sort of a
double double whammy here learning the
language and learning your methods um
where are you located by the way i'm in
california oh whereabouts uh near
sacramento north california
yeah we my wife and i were in palm
springs and we got out
21st of march
oh okay wow it was getting more and more
difficult to get out but yeah yeah yeah
well i think that's wonderful i think
you know
uh the whole movement towards online
instruction
uh people providing you know language
related services and teaching and and
resources online it's just it was
growing before but i think it's gonna
continue to grow
oh yeah you know i think the world
economy is gonna have to shift to more
of a you know more remote type
activities for quite a while i don't see
us quickly getting back to
yeah i mean as a teacher so you've been
affected you were about a high school
teacher
yeah so actually i was at a placement at
a middle school in my town so i did a
high school uh the first two months of
this year in january february and then i
transitioned to middle school i had only
been there two weeks before
the shutdown happened but i like that
you mentioned the transition to online
because i actually just finished uh
planning a lesson for our class for next
week this is technically spring break
for the kids down here so we're not
doing it we're honoring the spring break
even though they could technically get
on right but
uh we gave them that spring break and
then next week we're going to have our
first kind of real online lesson and
it's taken a while for the school to
adjust and my school is probably no
different than many other schools around
the country that are having math in math
this is in math yeah seventh grade you
have a big interest in languages and yet
you're a math teacher so yeah you cover
the the whole uh waterfront
um one of the things i've i was talking
to my son mark who's kind of the the guy
who runs link and
we were saying that a lot of the
approaches to sort of online teaching
from say the established k-12 system and
also for universities and colleges is
basically to take the classroom and put
it online right and that there hasn't
been a lot of developing of i mean there
is the famous can academy which is
pretty good of course yeah yeah but i i
wonder if do you see
that changing where teachers are going
to be a little more creative and how
they
they approach
their online instruction or is it just
gonna be
you know
uh uh classroom is online now rather
awesome
so happy you asked this question because
this is a question that i've been
grappling with actually very recently
because of my requirement to become a
teacher i have to satisfy certain
uh lesson requirements i have to make
certain things happen during these
lessons i can't just press record and
you know right whatever may happen i
can't do that so i have really been
trying to think of a way and with my i
have basically a supervisor teacher
who's helping me and with her we've been
trying to come up a way how do we hold
the kids accountable online because when
we're in a classroom environment regular
physical classroom environment it's easy
to give them a test or give them a quiz
or give them a warm up you can't really
do that online you kind of have to
change the way you think about
assessments the way you think about how
you're going to
receive feedback how the way how you're
going to tell that they're actually
learning so
i 100
agree and and telling you that all
teachers are going to have to adjust
like you can't just take the book and
take it online like it
you could but i don't think it would be
very effective
and you know there's
a couple of elements i was actually
listening to a podcast in arabic about
uh you know going online of course in
the arabic world they don't have the
resources that you have in the united
states or canada or elsewhere where
everybody has a computer and everybody
has a printer and all this kind of stuff
yeah so there were those
reasons why they were at a at a
disadvantage
and their kids are unhappy they're at
home they want to go to school one of
the things they mentioned which i think
is very important is the classroom is
not just a place where instruction takes
place it's a place where people
socialize so they socialize with each
other yeah they socialize with the
teacher in some way the teacher in fact
is a dis you know i wouldn't say a
source of discipline but the teacher is
kind of looking to make sure they're
working oh yeah so this whole social
aspect now and and and particularly kids
connecting with each other and so forth
that's got to be part of
the whole thing that takes if you take
instruction online and has that come up
in your discussions
it hasn't but i
that is something that i thought about
because especially now working in a
middle school it's actually more so
going down from it's weird because you
would think like you know you see all
the high school movies and you think oh
high school drama and all that stuff but
middle school
is where they are just learning those
things they are just kind of learning
you know how i
how do i distinguish myself socially and
what type of person do i want to be and
then you see them going through that
experimental phase so they definitely
really need that social aspect at that
developmental age and
yeah that's something that's difficult
to account for right it's something
that's difficult to apply to replace
online and because i know my school
we're not factoring that in we basically
have enough time to
check and see if they did what we wanted
them to do which we gave them lessons
and packets ahead of time and then we
have time to maybe teach a little bit
but that part's not built in yet so we
haven't gotten to where we're taking
taking i'm sure that
all of these things are going to evolve
oh yeah and there'll be some brilliant
ideas and i think we're in a world where
people share things more so that if
somebody in baltimore comes up with a
solution you'll be absolutely sharing it
around so i'm sure we could talk forever
but it's been a very interesting
discussion uh maybe we can introduce
link in the classroom uh in some way i
there are some teachers using it
uh
thank you very much uh for this
interview and thank you man hopefully
you can connect again sometime
yeah thanks a lot i really appreciate it
thank you keith and i'll leave a
connection the link to your podcast in
the description box sure i really
appreciate it thank you for your time
[Music]
you